Davina is in Jackson Mississippi hi
Davina how are you fine
good how can I help well I have done a
lot of extensive research in your CDs in
your books and I just wanted to get some
professional words of wisdom here and
see if our situation may be a little bit
different because my husband is going to
be itchy this year I'll be 49 he is
self-employed in construction and I
really don't think he's going to be out
there down in those manholes and pouring
concrete when he at 70 and 80 years old
so I'm wanting to find out if we should
be sticking with the cut-and-dry
snowball approach or if maybe we need to
be aiming more toward our retirement
funding and of course you know keeping
our bills current and getting things
paid off as we can but I've written down
right here after looking at the formula
for the retirement to monthly planning
that if we're warnings $50,000 a year
then by looking at the amount of mistake
that we need and multiplying that times
the factor for his age of 50 then we
would need to be putting aside one
thousand eight hundred and six dollars
and 25 cents per month toward retirement
if we're going to achieve that goal so
that right there is the first thing I'm
trying to figure out your household
income self-employed but um if we're
talking about what do you guys make a
year that's taxable income on average
okay
you get in the old net what I'm trying
to recall if I had to guess I would say
that is going to be about eighty before
tax that sounds probably right with the
other numbers you gave me how much debt
do you have not counting your house
we've got he owes approximately eight on
a trailer we have got a truck that's
financed for forty four six we have
still got seventy six hundred on a
credit card and we have got
approximately two thousand in doctor
bills okay you need to sell the truck
yes I agree we've been talking about
doing that basically okay
trucks out of control it's over half
your
come and tada look and that's what's
blocking you and then you do need to
stick with the debt snowball and clean
this up because your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income and
right now it's going out the door to
other people in the form of debt
payments so yeah you need to do your
debt snowball stop all investing and you
need to do it great great great focused
intensity lots of overtime beans and
rice rice and beans no life I'm scared
about retirement so much that I'm gonna
live like no one else and get out of
debt so later I can live and give like
no one else and you'll be okay you're
gonna get there because I think you've
woke up I think you woke up just in
talking to you and listening to you and
you've dialed in on this you're really
doing the research you're thinking about
it you've been on Chris Hogan's a
website and ran the are IQ is what
you're telling me there and I'm I'm
proud of you I think you're going to be
fine but you're going to have to clean
up the mess because the when you don't
have any payments but a house payment
then investing aggressively is very
possible but it's tough to do with a car
payment on a forty four thousand dollar
pickup that's kind of prohibitive to
doing all this and so yeah just work
your baby steps straight through you're
gonna be there faster than you feel
emotionally like you're there because
once you woke up you became suddenly
impatient which is wonderful that's
going to be the motivation that's going
to drive you through this process